all right so very quickly let me explain
this video I was thinking about taking
you through a walkthrough of one of my
days but the problem is every single day
is different so whatever I'm doing on
Monday may not be truly representative
of what I'm gonna be doing on Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday or Friday and being a
freelance web developer you're gonna
find that you're gonna be working at
different hours during the day and
sometimes over night so I figured let me
just try to throw into a video
everything that I possibly try to do
during a typical day and again there are
no typical days so watch the video
hopefully you enjoy it I'm gonna show
you some footage of what I do during
various days again remember I'm married
with three kids and I work from home so
hopefully enjoy this video they see what
time that says I see better focusing on
that 4:33 that's in the morning that's
crazy that's what it looks like outside
right now this is the time the champions
get up
[Music]
yes I pack everything mama I gotta show
you what's in my bag in my bag I have my
little MacBook Air that way I can code
whenever I have to undergo I have some
diapers
just about some pull-ups coz he's
actually using pull-ups now cuz this one
still needs it and of course we gotta
have water and I got his water there too
in the car we got the drone
he had a moped his moped the video
camera and the DSLR camera so you got a
lot of stuff in the bag
[Music]
what are we doing today
yeah today we're working right yeah all
right what's up everybody what's up
everybody my name is Joel I'm the
creator of vixen burp calm and this is
my son Gavin he is my assistant he
spends a lot of time with me whenever
I'm coding whenever I'm building
websites whenever I'm here working from
home I'm a freelance web developer I
create WordPress powered websites and I
do it from the distraction filled area
called my house and what I always try to
advocate that people try to get a
dedicated environment where they could
just strictly focus on the things they
have to work on sometimes that's not
possible so you have to be able to push
through and just get the job done
exactly right papa so this video is
about a day in the life of a freelance
web developer and in my case a wordpress
developer you know every day is
different no day is the same you know I
get up at different times every day I go
to sleep at different times every night
some days I'm working from home some
days I go outside and I work either from
a coffee shop or I've actually tried
working from the beach but that kind of
doesn't work out especially since when
it's so nice outside you just want to
relax under the Sun so that one may not
actually be something that saw a good
idea to do but working at a park is not
a bad idea working at a coffee shop is
awesome and being able to be mobile is
ideal because you can work from home but
you know sometimes you want to change up
your environment you want to change
scenes around a little bit of background
I'm married I have three kids and I
started coding later on in life it
wasn't my first career I didn't start
coding when I was in you know high
school and become one of those prodigy
type coders I learned bass out of
necessity and they're not a desire I
chose to change careers and I went from
being a suit and tie type of guide to
being a t-shirt or a polo shirt and
jeans type of guy
[Music]
[Applause]
and ever since making the transition I
haven't looked back I get to spend a
significant amount of time with my
family which is very important to me
like it exactly right and I get to spend
time working on the projects that I want
to work on yeah right this is my little
assistance over here he's gonna end up
finding something awesome in the future
and he's gonna be a million times better
coder than I am yeah you're a big boy
that's right high-five alright so in
preparation for making this video I
tried to figure out what would be the
best representation of a typical day and
again that's very difficult to try to
portray because every day is different
every day is unique that's it
so I figured I just laid out on the
table every day is different I get up at
different times in the morning go to bed
at different times tonight
some days I'm working on clients
websites some days I'm working on my
themes that I sell on my website click
some are calm and I do both because
you're not always gonna have clients in
the pipeline and that's something to
realize you need to find a way to make
some passive income so that's why I
chose to besides working on client
website and contract work I decided to
create some WordPress themes that I sell
on my website maybe people could buy
them from I've also taken part in
affiliate marketing and now creating
videos on YouTube so having the ability
to make some passive revenue and also
have some client working contract work
is vital to my workflow and going into
workflow that's different for everybody
I work on three different types of
systems I work primarily on my
workstation computer here which is a
windows-based computer and I built a
computer myself so that way I can have a
video editing rig and the triple monitor
setup makes it a lot more productive for
me but again this is the workstation
this space here I can't take this
anywhere with me at least not easily so
that's why I still also have my laptop's
I have
MacBook Pro and MacBook Air and I have a
Linux based laptop
was formerly a windows-based laptop
right right out windows and badman I
just put up Linux Mint on that laptop
and that allows me to be mobile so
whenever I'm working from home I'm most
likely working on this computer and then
whenever I'm outside I take one of the
laptops with me most often I take the
MacBook Air because that is the smallest
one
it's the 11 inch MacBook Air and this is
one of the best laptops because it's so
small so tiny and you can pretty much
take it with you anywhere the battery
life on it is pretty good this is not a
new one it's not 2012 but it's perfect
for you know coding on the go so this
definitely is always in my bag whenever
I'm going outside and actually that's
gonna be a good video to create what's
in my bag but that's for another time so
this is the MacBook Air that's what I
take when I'm on the go obviously I have
breakfast lunch and dinner I drink
coffee that's what keeps me up yeah yeah
Gavin drinks juice and yeah we're gonna
actually break for some lunch now so
we're gonna probably have to I made some
chicken nuggets so I think it's ready so
we're gonna start getting that now and
then we're gonna jump on the computer
and show you a little bit of what I do
yeah but we're not going to meet down
today anyway so I'm gonna break for
lunch right now and then I'm gonna take
some footage of typically what I do on
my computer I'll show some screenshots
of what I do on my coding process I work
with HTML CSS JavaScript PHP my sequel
and WordPress I use the visual studio
code text editor and sometimes I use
phpstorm as well I also have get as part
of my workflow because it's a great
version control and I use gulp as the
task runner that's an important part of
my workflow because it helps to take
care of the lower level processes that I
would take a significant amount of time
and again as I said you know I'm all
over the place some days I'm working
from home some days I'm working off-site
and time is money especially if you're
freelancers so you have to find every
single way you can to try to save time
so you can focus on the larger task at
hand
all right so bye now gonna break for
lunch
[Music]
all right so hopefully you found this
video helpful I wanted to provide you
for a little bit of insight of what a
freelancer does during the day and again
every single day's gonna be different
so to say there's gonna be a typical day
well that's not gonna tell you the whole
story because again one day gonna be
doing one project the next day you'll be
working on another project so you have
to be able to be adapt if you have to be
able to change your mindset and change
your workflow of course it's good to
have structure of course it's good to
try to schedule your day and try to plan
out what you're looking to accomplish
but instead of giving yourself a
schedule try to give yourself goals try
to identify what needs to get done on
any given day alright so hopefully you
found the video helpful if you did give
it a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe and if you're new to
freelancing hopefully this helped and
I'll see you next time take care
[Music]